foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
well
this morning
i knew i was going to be talking about
the nuremberg nazi rally in texas
where they declared that they are all
domestic terrorists but i did not have
on my monday morning bingo card
that we would find out that donald trump
was telling john kelly i want hitler's
style generals that's what i want i want
nazi generals that's what i want
oh my god i really i really thought the
majority of my day was going to be taken
up by talking about the nazi rally that
happened in texas
over the weekend where hungarian hitler
and the orange mussolini jesus came out
on stage with low energy by the way
but to the we're all domestic terrorists
wwf style
entries holy [ __ ]
i'm dead serious
that i'm not making this [ __ ] up
during the nazi rally the nuremberg
rally down in texas
they announced that they're all we're
all domestic terrorists
it's it's not
it's not a lie it's a thing they did
they did a lot of other stupid [ __ ]
there's a there's a goddamn video from
vice tess owen
she went in and was
looking at all the chinese-made
merchandise
the garbage that has trump's name all
over it
and uh she did a little video on that we
might watch that today but i have a
special guest joining us today to talk
about the nuremberg rally down in texas
rachel bittikoffer dr rachel
bitterkoffer is going to join us just
here in about 10 oh 10 minutes i think
she'll be joining us
to talk about the the nuremberg rally
down in texas but this morning we find
out that trump wanted hitler style
generals apparently he told john kelly i
want my generals to be more like
germany's
and john kelly had to say what what
generals the ones in germany during
world war ii
so the nazis is what he was saying now
the best part about the whole back and
forth
on the quotes
is that john kelly had to explain to
donald trump that in the end
in the end like near the end of nazi
germany the generals were the ones that
were trying to kill hitler he had to let
him know that he didn't have any
any clue the other
ridiculous part
about the news that is being
puked up today i don't know why we're
getting this news now
why why are we receiving that donald
trump wanted his generals to be like the
nazi germany generals
now
we're almost two years past the 2020
election where the [ __ ] was this
information
don't you think american people would
have made
much different decisions if they would
have known this [ __ ]
speaking of [ __ ] we watch as he flushes
elise stefanik's name down the toilet on
a set of notes i don't know if he wiped
his ass with him or what i know i don't
know this is very unclear we're getting
pictures from maggie haberman
which i don't know how long she's had
these pictures how long have you you
people been holding on to these pictures
oh
but i digress from that the other yeah
the other thing that he told john kelly
is he didn't want injured soldiers in
the 4th of july parade
he didn't want injured soldiers in the
4th of july parade because trump felt
like that made him look bad
and john kelly had to inform him
that the suckers and losers as trump's
refers to him that are injured
the ones that
are injured in battle
those are the heroes
trump did not know these things trump
did not know
that the injured veterans
the injured soldiers are our heroes
he did not know this and he also did not
know
that nazi germany's generals turned on
hitler in the end and were actually
trying to kill him and get rid of him
for the same reasons why 8 million more
people voted against trump because we do
not want your american style fascism you
white christian nationalist speaking of
that
we have um footage
from the nazi rally the nuremberg rally
where marjorie taylor green
says again out loud into a microphone
for a camera to see
that she is a white christian
nationalist and she loves being a white
christian nationalist and she's not
going to stop being white christian
nationalist
and people in georgia
should take her seriously i mean they're
telling you what they want to do folks
they're telling you what they want to do
part of its projection we watched is
rick
scott
the senator former governor former uh
medicaid medicare fraudster
stood on stage and said the democrats
are modern day book burners okay mr book
burner yourself get the [ __ ] out of here
with this nonsense
people i am sick and i tweeted this
morning i am [ __ ] sick of the bull
side [ __ ] i'm sick of it if you're still
claiming to be pro-democracy and the and
the words both sides comes out of your
[ __ ] mouth you are not pro-democracy
you can just hang up the [ __ ] phone
dot stop listening stop listening right
now because you're not gonna like what i
have to say you're just not going to
like what i have to say at this point
over the weekend
the democratic party worked in the
senate
and then
and on the hill to make sure that
americans receive relief through the
inflation reduction act
a lot of relief is in that bill now it's
kind of a small billback better bill
and republicans did their damnedest
they're damnedest to destroy that bill
they did their damnedest
they even tried to strip out the 35 cap
on insulin which in some cases they did
do that
but the democrats succeeded without
one republican vote not one because they
were more distracted about their little
nuremberg rally that they were having in
texas calling themselves domestic
terrorist i'm not [ __ ] you you're my
favorite turd i wouldn't do that
both sides get the [ __ ]
out of here with that bullside [ __ ] stop
stop your nonsense stop your [ __ ] if
you're still saying that and you're
still believing that you were just as
delusional as those dumb [ __ ]
who were praying
to at the cage of the [ __ ] fake ass
prisoner
down at the nuremberg rally where
marjorie taylor green got on her knees
and prayed with him or some [ __ ] i don't
know this guy this guy apparently
his name is brandon of all [ __ ] names
jesus christ this guy's brandon
brandon in the cage apparently this guy
turned on all the january sixers to get
himself a good deal with the feds and
here he is acting like he's crying in a
jail cell which the guy apparently
wasn't even didn't even
it's in a jail cell one goddamn date so
he was in a jail cell longer at the
nuremberg rally than he was actually in
a jail cell for january 6 because the
guy flipped on his cohorts which he
should have
by the way
but they hail him as some kind of hero
down at the nuremberg rally brandon hey
brandon you're going to be the first to
go
you're going to be the first to go dummy
that's how this is going to work
that's how it always works that's how it
works with fascist
they watch as the hungarian hitler
orban comes on stage that [ __ ] racist
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] wants to abolish
interracial marriage hmm sounds familiar
sounds familiar just like here in this
country which they're trying to do
they let him speak and they give him a
standing ovation
they give him a standing ovation
as if a rock star was coming on stage
this person is a [ __ ] fascist
he is trying to develop a fascist state
he is getting rid of freedom in hungaria
and these freedom fighters are standing
up cheering him
really dumb ass [ __ ] these people don't
know what rights they don't know what
freedom they don't know what liberty is
they have no [ __ ] clue they're
blinded they're delusional and you
people out there
who are saying both sides are the same
you're just as [ __ ] delusional that's
right i'm saying it you're just as
delusional
you're a bunch of dumbasses
here the president and the democrats are
working their asses off to try to pass
legislation to try to move agenda
forward for the american people
republicans at every turn tried to stop
him in the legislative body
but at the same exact time at the same
exact time
they're holding nazi rallies
and that's probably why they don't have
an interest in actually legislating i
mean it's so much more fun to run down
to texas to the nurember rally
as the orange mussolini jesus comes on
stage with his low energy what was that
holy [ __ ]
he's really lost his luster hasn't he
ah one too many big macs my friend in
retirement need to lay off the need to
lay off the [ __ ] fast food my friend
holy [ __ ] you look like [ __ ] and you're
low energy someone should have given
that son of a [ __ ] adderall before he
walked on stage
we're gonna watch some clips of this
thing but here in just a few minutes
now rachel bittikoffer is going to join
us
to talk about the nuremberg rally and
her view of the nuremberg rally and why
it's so important in the body politic
because folks we got to politicize the
[ __ ] out of this
we have to politicize the [ __ ] out of
this that'll help shut up the bull
sizers
because that [ __ ] ain't help helping
that [ __ ] ain't helping
i got nina turner that's right i'm gonna
call her out nina turner complaining
about oh this bill inflation bernie
sanders trying to
put amendments in and he voted for it
he voted for it 50 to 50.
you people really believing some of this
nonsense of this bull side stuff you're
just as delusional as the moglodites you
really are
you really are
i'm sorry to say it i want you on our
side i want you to be pro-democracy i
want you to be right there with us and
we need you we have to have you
to save this country possibly
but you gotta you gotta pluck your head
out of your ass you gotta do it you just
gotta understand that that a hundred
percent of nothing is [ __ ] nothing
and really a hundred percent of nothing
sometimes is a fascist state
speaking of fascist state liz cheney
this morning has told ron desantis to go
[ __ ] himself
not in so many words that's the way i
would put it darth vader jr said she
would not support ron desantis in a
presidential bid because he is a donald
trump ii type thing donald trump 2.0
he's a fascist he's a nazi
really rich coming from her who has
voted for everything that donald trump
and ron desantis would want to do but
i digress from that i believe that this
is a full-on assault from liz cheney to
trumpism
i believe that's what this is this
morning where she's
sending shots over the bow
to the new donald trump because it's
clear after this weekend on stage that
that the old version of donald trump
does not have the wherewithal to
withstand another election he does not
he'll barely make it through this one
i mean he's gonna have losses
and catastrophic losses in these
elections folks because of you because
of you pro-democracy people out there
because you're engaging in your
democracy you're engaging in the ballot
you're doing the things that you need to
do
and it's working they know it's working
there's a new ad this morning out
against harsh herschel herschel walker
in georgia
from republicans accountability project
which
is very damaging to herschel walker
we know in pennsylvania john fetterman
is absolutely trouncing dr oz
same way as tim ryan
in ohio
and my guess is mark kelly will keep his
his special seat as is the way warnock
will
betto's kicking ass in texas
it's folks and it's you
you are the reason why all these things
are happening you're the reason
you're the reason why democrats are
getting things done
you are the reason
you think republicans had anything to do
with passing the pact act nope not a
goddamn thing they tried to stop it
until you
yelled and screamed
do you think do you think there would
have been enough political capital over
the weekend to pass the the inflation
reduction act without you
nope democrats got it done because of
you
they know you're there standing behind
them and you must you must stand sturdy
behind the the party of democracy
because there's only one party of
democracy at this point
only one
and it's the democrats the republicans
aren't interested in the democracy if
you watch two seconds of the nuremberg
rally
in texas over the weekend you would
realize that there is only one only one
party that is interested
in democracy at all only
one
and it's not the republicans
it's not that's why liz cheney this
morning again is telling ron desantis to
go [ __ ] off
she understands the stakes here she
knows what you desire which is a
democracy regardless of which side of
the democracy she stands on she
understands that
and so does dick cheney dick cheney
understands that
so did mark milly apparently there's
more news there's a fire hose on news
this morning i'm hoping we can get to it
all in the [ __ ] list roundup uh rachel
bittikoffer is going to be joining us um
i think uh
and i know if our camera's working here
let's let's see if we can get rachel in
here rachel can you hear me i don't
think no i don't think she's
it's not working over on her end at this
point she i don't know if she's uh
having trouble with service or not but
rachel will be dr rachel bitterkover
will be joining us hopefully soon to
talk about the nuremberg rally
in texas to give us her low down you
know rachel always gives us the
perspective of why we why it is good for
politics and how to politicize it
and if you're not watching her twitter
account you need to be that is a great
way to engage in your ballot by taking
some of the words that rachel
bittikoffer uses and some of the phrases
and language that she uses
to to talk to your community members
your neighbors your friends your family
your coworkers the people who go to the
pta with you
your
fellow church parishioners if you're
still attending church
even the people at the grocery store at
the wally world
the gas station that you talk to
even those folks you should engage in
your ballot that is how democracy works
and it's working it is working folks it
is working
the the organ the organized front
against trumpism is working
the messaging is working
the messaging of community you look at
the john fetterman campaign and you look
at the betto campaign and tim ryan too
there's a there's there's things that
prop up pop up in their campaign
language
not not exactly the same but it's this
community talk
it's about the state of pennsylvania the
state of ohio the state of texas their
community
because what is democracy if it's not
community folks
and what is community if it's not
democracy
and i believe you pro-democracy people
out there understand this better than
any other
voting bloc on earth when you consider
yourself pro-democracy and you engage in
the ballot in a in a way
that serves the institution of democracy
i believe we will get to equality in
inequity
sooner than you believe i believe that
roe will be codified sooner than you
believe
i believe we will undo a lot of the
damage that these fascists have done in
our country sooner than you believe
you just have to have the belief in
yourself and have the strength
to continue to push forward let's take a
quick break i'm going to check on rachel
bittikoffer to see if we can get her
right after these messages stick around
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your part in blanket today for just
99.99
actual partying is not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
back to the tony michaels podcast thanks
for joining us every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific right here on
youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcasting
from the midas touch facebook page
i'm still trying to help rachel dr
rachel bittikoffer coming on the show
she's having trouble she's out in the
pickup truck you know rachel does um
some of her interviews here on the tony
michaels podcast from her pickup truck
and i think she's having a problem with
service she just doesn't have enough
service wherever she's at
to connect so um hopefully we will
be able to bring her in she's trying
again let's see if we can we can get her
in here on the show but i think she's
having trouble with with her service
wherever she is parked she's in her
truck i think this morning so we were
going to do a truck interview i always
liked the truck interviews from rachel i
always like to truck interviews let's
see if we can bring her in let's see if
this works yeah rachel can you hear me
can you hear me no i don't i don't i
don't think she has enough service
we're having those technical
difficulties
on that end it's thinking it's thinking
it's thinking it really wants to bring
dr rachel bittikoffer on the show but
it's not i just don't think she has
enough service possibly
i don't think she has enough service
where she's at
so hopefully rachel can join us i know
she's got a heart out here in about 20
minutes
but hopefully she can join us at least
for 10 or 15 minutes if she gets some
service and she joins us here on the
tony michaels podcast
um
she she's having trouble with her
service let's see if we can try her one
more time let's see if rachel
bittikoffer's phone will connect
no it's not connecting on my end
gosh darn it
[Laughter]
um we'll miss you rachel
i'm gonna type her a message that we'll
miss you
so everyone knows
um
rachel knows that we gave her a shout
out at least at least in a private
message so i'm sad to see that rachel
does not have enough service to join us
this morning but
maybe tomorrow or wednesday we'll bring
her in to talk about the nuremberg
rally
oh boy there's a lot of footage from
nuremberg rally there's also a lot
a lot
a lot of news this morning it's like a
fire hose there was a lot of news last
week like a lot of good news last week
there was a lot of good news
and there's almost as much news packed
in this morning as there was in the
entire week last week
whoa baby so let's do this let's go to
and let's you know we what we do on the
show here uh gabe is still traveling
this morning from his uh
other secret underground bunker so he
will not be joining us you just have me
this morning
you just have me it's just me me you and
the [ __ ] list roundup so let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the
podcast we have reached the part of the
show where we round up all the tweety
tweets and eternity trends and the [ __ ]
last round up boy do we have a lot of
[ __ ] to round up today and we got a lot
of time to do we got about an hour and a
half to round up all the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends that is what we're
doing today because there's so much of
it
so let's just get right down to it and
let's go to the uh
let's go to the timeline let's go all
the way down here we don't want to uh
get into too new of news we want to get
some older news here
um because there's
older news over the weekend
with this vote uh marco rubio was in the
news of course
the cheeto dust mobster oh our friend
alex stein making it back in the news oh
alex stein he's a serial harasser
he blocked me by the way what a [ __ ]
that's right alex stein99 i hope you're
listening you're such a [ __ ] wimp
you know this guy approaches women
he accosted aoc on the steps he sexually
harassed women on reality tv shows and
then he approached another credentialed
reporter
inside of the nuremberg rally
and harassed her with with with press
credentials around his neck apparently
of course he would get press credentials
at a nuremberg rally this tucker carlson
type
but then he goes on to harass a female
reporter who's just doing her job just
reporting for vice news this [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
so we'll we'll go through how much of a
wimp he really is he's scared of me
apparently i mean he's scared to be
approached by me
all i did was bring up that he's a
serial harasser that he harassed aoc
hell he was proud of it that's all i did
i just said it was a pattern that's all
i said
and he blocked me
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay let's go down there
there's a lot of stuff
um here is the
let's go to uh some more despicable [ __ ]
that the republicans did oh both sides
are the same both sides are exactly get
the [ __ ] out of here senate fails to get
60 votes to include insulin cap and
inflation reduction act it will now be
removed from the bill
all the democrats
all of them voted for it every last one
of them
here you go here's the video from c-span
2.
i'm tim kaine saying nope this uh
we're going to have to take this out
let's listen
on this vote the yeas are 57
the nays are 43.
three-fifths of the senators duly
chosen and sworn not having voted in the
affirmative the motion is not agreed to
the point of order is sustained and the
language will be stricken from the
amendment
boom they took out the 35 cap hmm
seems like republicans don't want
don't want insulin to be capped for
americans [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] well
that's not surprising is it it's not
surprising that they're so focused on
being terrorists down in texas
that they would forget that they might
have to do something for the american
people and of course here is my here's
my tweet here's my quote tweet of it
both parties are the same
they're not the same folks it's that's
all nonsense quit believing that
[ __ ] when someone says that to you
know that they're a [ __ ] idiot oh
here's more alex stein [ __ ] the patriot
take says maybe we'll go through that
oh a becky sue video but
oh here's uh
bobo the clown
yeah i said projection is strong with
this one let's listen it's only 14
seconds
we're gonna listen to a lot of scuzz
bags this morning there's a lot of
scumbag clips this morning if you're
so if you want to stick around for the
scumbag clips this is the show here we
go
we need to investigate fauci we need to
defund bounty and we damn well need to
prosecute anthony fauci
what is the head bob thing what is that
when she bobs her head
is that like agree with me please you
remember when uh jeb bush stood and he
said please clap
please clap
i think that's what she's doing and
she's saying please agree with me right
without saying it out loud i don't know
i can't figure it out
i can't figure it out
but here she wants to she wants to pra
investigate fouchy
wants to prosecute fouchy now do trump
dummy now do yourself dummy do marjorie
taylor green do biggs do goes-r do matt
getz
do roger stone what about alex jones how
about paul manafort huh for giving
russians all the data he admits now this
today that oh yeah you goddamn right i
gave it to the russian spies you [ __ ]
ain't right i gave i gave trump campaign
information to russian intelligence why
wouldn't they they were trying to help
us win
[ __ ] idiots
bunch of [ __ ] idiots
the projection is strong with this one
of course she's being investigated
she's being investigated
in colorado so not surprising that she
would call for someone else's
investigation
uh here's herschel walker we're going to
get to the ad later but here's a video
that popped up over the weekend for
herschel walker for senate so if you're
down in georgia or you're helping uh
warnock win in georgia and stacey abrams
win in georgia this might be of interest
to you let's listen
i started going to the library getting
booked sitting in front of mirror
reading to myself
he would sit in front of the meter
mirror and read to himself that makes
sense these people would seem like they
would sit in front of a mirror and look
at themselves as they talk makes sense i
heard from that all the kids that were
[ __ ] what what was that i'm gonna
pull gabe sanchez wha what was that
did he say did he yeah that's what he
said let's listen
to his class
graduated at the university of georgia
in the top 1 of his class
my graduating class in college
instances you've exaggerated that story
you said that you graduated from uga
when they never said that they they said
that was and i said that's what you got
to remember i never i never have said
that statement not one time
oh [ __ ] yeah there's no such thing as
video anymore right marshall walker's
such a [ __ ] and chris puts it just
right he is unfit
to serve
in the senate that's the tweet
completely unfit to serve hey here's
here's um
here's here's a bit of rachel
bittikoffer's
feeling since we can't get her to join
us she's having uh cell phone service
issues
i might as well read one of her tweets
she says hey at meet the press are you
planning on normalizing the fascist
rally republicans just held in texas in
your coverage tomorrow first fascist
rally ever hosted by a major american
party
do you agree it was a it was fascist
rhetoric i absolutely agree
i agree hundred percent with a racial
bitter golfer
and i'm i'm i'm kind of sad that we
didn't get to talk about this this
morning because of her cell phone
service but i'm sure i'm sure
we'll get to talk about it sometime this
week here's a hoof foot green
i'm talking about how she's a fascist
let's listen the old party is done the
old republican party is over yeah we
know we know the old party's over we get
it we get it the republican party
doesn't exist anymore you're just you're
just walking around with the label
on your fascist ass we get it we
understand that like everyone should
realize and that's what i'm keep [ __ ]
telling you about the bulls side [ __ ]
there are no both sides because there's
not two parties there's not
let her explain it to you america first
is now the only way and the trump
republican party is going to be the
party that wins the fascist the nazis
we're gonna be the nazis
that's what she's saying
listen and believe them when they're
telling you this stuff
they're telling you out loud
yeah there was a great michael beschloss
had a great uh
i posted a link
maybe maybe we'll go watch one of those
videos or at least the trailer um to
this documentary
from
um
i believe it's i forget what the the
group is called but they did a
documentary in the 1939
1939 america first rally
that's right
1939 they had an america first rally
in the united states i'm not [ __ ]
you
it was a doozy too
they actually had nazi flags and real
nazis
at the 1939 america first rally now here
we are in 2022 holding another america
first rally for the for the conservative
they're not conservative for the
republican they're not republican the
[ __ ]
white christian nationalist
self-proclaimed american nazis speaking
of american nazis watch this weird ass
[ __ ] this is
this is a cage a jail cell that was set
up at
the nuremberg rally down in texas
and it appears to have a barefoot
prisoner with a manga hat on now there's
a lot of things wrong with this
a lot of things number one no jail cell
really it looks like this and number one
number two
you're not gonna wear a maga hat in a in
a jail okay it's not that's not gonna
happen that's not gonna happen
that that's not gonna happen and number
number three
why why would they why would they want
marjorie taylor greenen to
kneel at your feet get on her knees and
i don't know let's watch this
pressure
to do something about it when we get
those house back
look at these people
look at these [ __ ] delusional people
i think this is real or some [ __ ]
apparently this guy's name is brandon
i'm not [ __ ] you i'm telling you you
can't make this [ __ ] up this guy's
actual name is brandon
it's sitting in the cage he was there on
january 6th he turned on on his fellow
insurrectionists so that he could get a
good deal
apparently he got a couple months worth
of home confinement or some [ __ ]
because he turned on his friends
right and here he is down at the
nuremberg rally pretending that he spent
time in prison
for the january 6 insurrection
and here he is and here these people are
just i mean it's not surprising though
this woman here standing here crying
look at her t-shirt
she's got a t-shirt on as if donald
trump is a great american he's a [ __ ]
treasonous piece of [ __ ] we know that
now this morning talking about how he
wants hitler generals i want more hit i
want more generals like hitler had god
damn it
let's let's let's watch
oh she's really broken up she's real
upset
oh jesus christ
she's really breaking up here oh my god
let continue
you know there's more than one message i
would like to get across
there's more than one message he'd like
to get across as if you know all the
messages that were being portrayed here
aren't enough
all the contradictions all the [ __ ]
all the all the dumb [ __ ] that is
what this performance art thing is i
guess that's what they thought it was
now here's the thing here's the funniest
part about it all
for several hours for several hours
gabe sanchez my co-host and executive
producer he's not here this morning but
we should call him out
he was receiving messages i was even
getting messages
if this was gabe like literally people
were tagging me
at the tony michaels is this at i am
gabe sanchez
did he go down to texas did he is he
doing performance art at cpac i'm like
no no he did not go to the nuremburg
rally
but a lot of people thought some of the
first images that came from this this
weirdo doing this whatever the hell he's
doing here he calls it performance art
it seems like political political
theater more than anything
uh
they thought it was gabe sanchez that's
hilarious that's hilarious i tried to
get daniel dale to fact check
but he was nowhere to be found let's
continue uh
if i kept it as general as possible what
i would like to say i guess at this
point is
that even for the people i think
everybody is in agreement that anybody
who committed
violence vandalism who caused extreme
fear on that day
needs to pay an appropriate price for
what they did
so all of them all of them that entered
the capital then is what you're saying
that that's what you're saying brandon
i'm not [ __ ] you i i think it's
straw straska stratzka i don't know what
a [ __ ] name is his name is brandon
his name is [ __ ] i don't know
but there are a lot of people who are
suffering i think unduly i think it's
very disproportionate to what they
actually did
and even more than that
i would like to say at this point that
the hatred on both sides
more of the bull side [ __ ] you see what
i'm saying do you see what i'm saying
about the both side [ __ ] you follow me
you catch me right here in this
motherfucker's word salad right here in
his word salad because this this this
whole thing this whole [ __ ] jail cell
and to feel sorry for the for for the
[ __ ] insurrectionists the treasonous
pieces of [ __ ] that tried to overthrow
our vote try to throw our government in
the name of their mussolini jesus [ __ ]
you
bull sizing if you keep saying the words
both sides out loud that [ __ ] lie you
keep repeating that lie even if you
think you're a pro-democracy person
and you're for democracy and you're for
america and you're against the
republicans when you say both sides and
you tweet out that you're comparing well
both sides do this both sides do that
well to both sides in a boat in a boat's
eye bro you're
you're
repeating
their nazi propaganda
got it
do you follow me do you see what i mean
you see why it's so important that you
shut that [ __ ] [ __ ] up
just shut it down shut that [ __ ] down
there is no they are not the same the
parties are not the same not even
[ __ ] close
not even [ __ ] close there are no two
parties really that's the problem that
we actually have we have a two-party
system in this country
a two-party system that is that is a
democratic constitutional republic a
democracy and only one of those parties
is is interested in democracy the other
wants to undo it that's the problem that
we're actually having
they're not the both sides are not
interested in democracy
they're not the same
it's nonsense
to stop
it's
it's time to forgive people who made
mistakes on both sides no no it is not
time to forgive
people who made mistakes on both sides
what the time is now is to politicize
the [ __ ] out of what you people did to
our country and our democracy how you
tried to bang it up and how you tried to
destroy it that's what it's time to do
time for forgiveness we're not we're not
even to the forgiveness part
of this of this trauma here friend not
even [ __ ] close to forgiveness part
you [ __ ] have to admit what you
did before you get forgiven that's how
that [ __ ] works and you [ __ ]
aren't even close
close and it is clear from this
nuremberg rally down in texas that you
are not even [ __ ] close
not even close to the stage of admitting
what the [ __ ] you did to our democracy
it's time to start seeing each other as
human beings again and it's time to stop
enjoying and taking pleasure in the
suffering of other people real [ __ ]
rich coming from this from the nazi
rally real [ __ ] rich they want to
take rights away from lgbtq they want to
take rights away from women from 10 year
old girls from having the rights over
their own bodies
they want to force bursts on women and
little girls
but he oh he's he's all about he's all
about treating people like they're human
get the [ __ ] out of here with this
nonsense
nonsense absolute nonsense again when
you're talking about both sides and [ __ ]
you're playing right into the nazis
propaganda hands
we have an
audience kind of built in here
uh we had already decided to have a
booth and get that okay i can't i can't
i can't [ __ ] do any more of this
[ __ ] can't do it anymore can't
do that [ __ ] anymore thank you rex for
retweeting that we'll give some credit
here
um i want to show you
here you go
here is the uh here's here's the proof
here is
kamala harris
uh casting the the tiebreaker vote
to pass
the inflation reduction act for the
american people let's watch
on this vote the a's are 50 the nays are
50. the senate being equally divided the
vice president votes in the affirmative
and the motion to proceed
is agreed to the clerk will report the
bill
calendar
boom there it is
there it is
there's the clerk reporting the bill
they break the tiebreaker um this goes
back i'm sure nancy pelosi will get this
to the president's desk as soon as
possible
uh
pinned myself did you guys know that
jordy got married over the weekend
going to the chapel and
jordy got married
uh ben's little brother jordy got
married this weekend everyone go to
jordy's page jordy mizella's page uh
it's it's midas jordy
if you're wanting to know his handle
we'll we'll go over there and i'll show
you a video
but uh they were at his is his wedding
this weekend but ben was still all over
tweeting they were still keeping up with
the news ben tweets dark brandon
has it all in motion don't question him
don't doubt him
just watch the process and behold thank
you dark brandon for this bountiful
legislation known
as the inflation reduction act i'm
trying to make it you know i don't know
this dark brandon stuff is is hilarious
the reason why the dark brandon stuff is
hilarious is because like we're doing it
like i look at it as a troll to the
trump supporters who take the [ __ ] that
they post seriously you know what i'm
talking about they're like hey i take
that [ __ ] seriously they think this [ __ ]
is
the [ __ ] is real and stuff here is um
let's see here that's adam parkaminko's
uh tweet of um
of of the jordy
jordy wedding mr and mrs jordy my my
zealous wedding now there they're
kissing getting their pictures taken
thanks adam for the uh for the tweet so
everyone go
and there's um
there's jordy's handle minus jordy uh
for everyone to go
um and and
tell him congratulations
on tying the knot
with uh mrs jordy myself so go and over
the weekend they had a beautiful wedding
it was it was great here is here's the
point where
um jordy decided to cry
um you see you see big brother ben there
in the background he officiated look at
look at jordy
let's watch
jordy break up
[Music]
as his bride comes down the
the aisle
i know all the midas mighty out there
have a special place in their heart for
jordy
and since we
simulcast on the minus touch facebook
page i figured we would
we would tell jordy congratulations
today on the show so
congratulations jordy
congratulations on your wedding starting
your family i know i know
that jordy will make one hell
one hell of a family man what do you
guys think so go go to jordy's page
and let him know
that you congratulate him on tying the
knot with his beautiful bride
so go go to jordy's page and wish him um
a happy life with his wife
so speaking of people who probably do
not have a happy life with their wife we
have a representative in in indiana
indianapolis he represents john jacob
john jacob jingle heimersmith
oh this [ __ ] guy this [ __ ] guy you
saw this i know i know you saw this
video over the weekend there's no way
you didn't notice this video somewhere
on the internet
you had to have i'm really disappointed
that this video only has 481 000
views folks this needs to have 480
million views
and the reason why is because what this
piece of [ __ ] says in here because this
is what
the republican party wants this is what
they they were saying as [ __ ] same [ __ ]
at the nuremberg rally down in texas
this weekend
as the nazis can mean to listen to
hungary hungarian hitler and the orange
mussolini jesus but let's listen to
representative john jacob what he wants
to what he wants to do with a woman's
body
this is his perspective
this is a white old white man with his
perspective on a woman's body i'm sure
it's just a hot take
the body
inside of the mom's body is not
her body let me repeat that the body
inside of the mom's body
is not her body
not her body
not her choice
okay not her body not her choice yet
another not her body not her choicer now
when it comes to mask i'm sure this
[ __ ] was out on the street
corner holding the sign my body my
choice but but when there's an umbilical
cord
and and another another a fetus
the woman's uterus nope not your body
not your choice he says women women do
not have the right to their body
only john jacob jingleheimer smith here
has the right to a woman's body in
indiana he has the right as as as a
state legislator to tell you what you
can and can't do with your body as a
matter of fact he's a fascist
why wouldn't a fascist want to tell a
woman what to do with her body when to
do it and how to do it or what not to do
this piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm telling you folks they're giving you
everything you need to politicize this i
am so disappointed that this video has
less than a half a million views this
should have a billion views as far as
i'm concerned and it's up to you you can
spread this around i'm telling you
when when you're trying to talk to
someone and they're like oh well
overturning roe v wade isn't that big of
a deal it just makes it a state issue
and it's not like anyone wants to really
take rats away from women and it's not
that we're trying to say women aren't
our second class citizens or anything
get this [ __ ] out and show it to
him
now he says something that's really
important at the end here
and he's really upset about a couple
words
that people keep using
and he's projecting here
remember they're always projecting so we
know
we can know what to do with their words
because we know it's projection that's
how we politicize it
watch watch what happens when he says
this and then watch how i handle it in
the tweet watch
trying to end all abortion is not
not
forced birth
he says trying to end abortion is not
not
not
forced birth
so he is really upset he is really upset
that some people are saying that it's
worse birth which that's what it is
john jacob jingleheimer smith
it's
it's forced birth you forced birther and
that's exactly what i say
i say they hate the words forced birth
so let's brand them hints forth
forced birthers
they're not pro-lifers anymore folks
they're forced birthers
and when you say just keep this video
handy hell you all you got to do if you
go down here to this little tab here
this little thing right here see this
here you just click on this little send
button
and you can put it in your bookmark
tweets
hell sometimes you can even download it
you know or retweet it quote tweet it if
you embed or quote tweet it then you can
pin it to the top of your page
the point is have it somewhere handy
save the link to the tweet i don't give
a [ __ ] what you do
screenshot it go spread it around other
pieces of social media that would be a
great thing too
but when someone when you call them
force birthers let's say you're with
your aunt sally right and aunt sally's
talking about you know abortion this
abortion that women shouldn't have the
right to their body yakity smackdown
right
you've heard it you've heard it all and
you call her a forced birther she's like
what you call me a forced birther we're
not trying to force birth just show them
this
show them this video you show them this
video yeah that's exactly what they're
trying to do because they're saying
they're not doing it
that's how i know
that these republicans are trying to
force births is because they're saying
they're not doing it
that's how i know
that's how i know here is the video
from the cpac this is the video
uh from tess owen of vice news
this video is fantastic it just oh man
it just shows how
how crazy they are now i actually i
actually said may the griff be with you
but here's what i actually think
why why don't we have a circus like this
can you imagine how many american jobs
we could create if we created all kinds
of crazy ass merchandise that that
pro-democracy people would go by if we
if we act if we made it all in the
united states you know of course all the
[ __ ] in this video is all main china
all of it all all that's made in china
which you know whatever
but they claim they're america first and
and then the entire
arena is filled with merchandise it's
made in china
miracle first yeah my [ __ ] ass
but why why shouldn't we as as
pro-democracy
people the party of democracy why
shouldn't we have our own little
circus that we have every every month or
every two weeks or however often they
have these nuremberg rallies now seems
like every goddamn two weeks they're
turning around and having a nazi rally
but why shouldn't we have our own circus
i think we should have our own circus it
would create a lot of american jobs to
sell off uh pro-democracy merchandise to
have
pro-democracy people meet and gather and
network i think that would be a good
thing i think it would be a good thing
for our democracy it works it works for
them i mean for the wrong reasons you
know but i mean it works so why not do
it but watch this video of these people
with this merchandise it is
oh boy it's something else we have ultra
mega hats we have trump 2024 hats
actually been selling for a couple of
years we have trump 2024 hats that we've
been selling for a couple of years think
of think about that for a second
he's saying he said that they've been
selling trump 2024 hats for a couple
years this is 2022.
if you rewind a couple years ago
we weren't even to the 2020 election
that's how [ __ ] gullible these people
who are buying this [ __ ] are watch
this this hat which says i could blank a
a bet a
they really are dumb [ __ ] i could [ __ ]
a better president that's not a bad
thing i mean depending on who's
president but buck fighting come on man
come on just say [ __ ] just say [ __ ]
buying you a bunch of wimps beautiful
c pack
bling purse
perfect for a cell phone piece of credit
card
you could you could put you could put
your nurnberg rally attending attending
badge inside the uh the nazi purse you
could do that it would fit right in
there
that the lanyard and all would go in
there
with your patriot mobile phone that's
going to be subpoenaed by the fed soon
oh my god hide out on the town
pastries for sale
oh look they have manga hat cupcakes
these people man
can you imagine how nasty that goddamn
thing tastes
can you imagine how nasty that thing is
oh my god it's a vanilla and strawberry
filled i'm here in dallas texas covering
cpac today i'm going to give you a
little tour through the wild world of
maga cpac merchandise
vendors are selling anything and
everything trump and maga here there are
children's books like this one plot
against the king based they're selling a
children's book called plot against the
king
i can only give you one guess only one
of who they think the king is
on false conspiracies that trump had the
election stolen from him i even had a go
paying to stop the steel board game in
the game we kind of did a timeline it's
the russia hoax
then
china virus okay they got a they got a
[ __ ] board game guys they got a board
game they got a [ __ ] board game are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me they got a
[ __ ] board game
oh lord
keep going
the mostly peaceful protest quote summer
of love and then campaign follies we
have a fake news cards the corruption
now someone pointed this out in the
comments if you look down here in the
corner of this card this golden state
whatever the [ __ ] they're talking about
here this fake news card whatever it is
it says election 2020.
this is a lot of stale goods someone
pointed that out in the comments i don't
know who it was
but they pointed out that this is this
is [ __ ] that's a couple of years old
this isn't like new stuff you can see it
up here 20 20 up here too
whoosh sim cards and the trigger cards
there are hats t-shirts socks slippers
commemorative plates fills with trump's
face on it and more
it's enough to make you [ __ ] puke
that's what it is it's enough to make
you puke now i want to i want to go to
another because that was tess owen of um
vice news
and she actually got harassed um because
she posted that video and she was
posting she was doing some threads on
twitter
um and i commented on her threads but
you had um
you and that net uh serial harasser here
he is here's the serial harasser
alex stein
harassing a woman who has press
credentials and apparently he has
progress press credentials too i'm not
going to play this whole thing because
it's [ __ ] gross
look at this [ __ ] again
so this is the vice reporter you can
tell the only one in a mask here so how
are you doing
just doing my job she's here trolling
everybody here so she's the only one
here in a mask and she's just saying
negative stuff i can't believe they let
you in here do you feel like you're
lying or sheep in the lines then
um i have credentials to be here yes
yes so do i i have credentials to come
harass other people with credentials
this is this is this is [ __ ] the
nuremberg rally for you folks what's
crazy is and this alex salvi oh i think
that's how you say his name he's a
correspondent he's a four correspondent
with newsmax okay
he says yeah this isn't cool
like literally the the guy with newsmax
folks the guy the newsmax guy's like
yeah
probably not cool to do this
even the newsmax guy thinks that
alexstein99
is a scumbag
i don't know if you guys agree with me
i'm sure you do and i tried to point it
out to him right i tagged him here on
this tweet
i said even the newsmax guy thinks alex
99 is a scumbag i was just pointing out
to alex that this guy was calling him a
scumbag really
i wasn't i mean i wasn't trying to you
know be mean or anything i was trying to
point out what was going on i wasn't
trying to be mean to alex
i would never you know approach alex
in a certain way
you know i
i said what happened alex 99 you know
like being approached of course he
blocked me you know
and it may have been because i said this
because i actually reached i quote
tweeted his video
and i said alex stein harassing women
again seems to be a pattern i'm just
saying i'm just pointing things out just
point things out i'm not trying to you
know be mean or anything
just
trying to get [ __ ] straight and he
blocked me see i can't even you can't
even see it anymore
because he blocked me he blocked he
forgot to block the podcast account at
least as far as i i can tell he forgot
to block that
i guess that'll be the next count
because he blocked he blocked gabe for
gabe's video about him so now speaking
of creepers with women here is uh the
former guy he tries to give a kiss um to
someone coming up on stage here and she
is having absolutely none of that [ __ ]
watch this this is [ __ ] hilarious
crazy it was the largest applause i've
ever heard come on up here look at this
look at this
[Applause]
sick [ __ ] annie he's a sick
piece of [ __ ] he's ready he's ready to
grab her by the something watch watch
when he moves in on her it's it i don't
know if she like took classes from
melania here or what but man
she really dunks on him here watch
he's ready to move in
oh he's gonna get ready for it yeah no
get the [ __ ] away from me
crazy it was the largest applause i've
ever heard come on up here look i wonder
if melania is running like a like a
school or something you know like anyone
around him and um
he can um and she runs a school on how
to handle him when he moves in on you i
bet that's it i bet that's it let's
watch it one more time it's fantastic
let's watch him get rejected
in front of cameras the world and his
little uh brown shirts look at this
look at this
[Applause]
nope get the [ __ ] away from me you sicko
grace
um
and her name is riley gaines i don't
know i guess she's a swimmer i have no
idea i i don't know
i don't know he tried to give her a kiss
she was having none of it which i don't
blame her i wouldn't want to go within a
500 feet of him even if i i actually
feared that if i was within 500 feet of
him i might hawk a loogie on him that
would be my fear you know i wouldn't
want to spread around any disease or
anything uh
speaking about diseases and here's
marjory taylor green
and talking let's see i think this is
the clip yeah this is where she's
talking about the the capital attack
and she's uh reframing it again in a
different way even though she just
visited the prisoner in the cell who has
a manga hat on and she prayed with him
let's listen to now how she frames it
real honest i'm always honest about it i
was upset that day
listen okay here's the thing
you do not you do not go and you not say
i'm always honest i want to tell you
down this truth listen let's be honest
but you know i want to be honest with
you like you weren't already you haven't
been being honest uh jesus this [ __ ]
gay
i was a brand new member of congress i'd
worked very hard on objecting to joe
biden's electoral college votes because
i believe that that was my role and what
i was what i wanted to do and i believe
it was the right thing i would do it
today i'd do it tomorrow
but i was very upset i never expected
anything like that and when it happened
i thought this is the antifa and no one
else convinced me it was
so-called trump supporters
but and and we know they're i can't i
can't even i can't even wrap my head
around like the stupidity like they they
can't even they can't even stay on their
own message folks how in the [ __ ] how
the [ __ ] are we so scared of these
[ __ ]
how
how you could politicize the absolute
[ __ ] out of this
you could politicize the [ __ ] out of
this just this one event down there at
this nuremberg rally down there in texas
you take her
you know getting on her knees
and i don't know what she was doing with
brandon in the jail cell that the the
political prisoner in the in the fake
ass jails it's always fake it's always a
fraud in it he wasn't actually a
prisoner
he didn't serve any prison time he
actually was at the capitol for
fraudulent reasons
uh they've set up a fraudulent fake jail
cell he's a fake prisoner and a fake
congresswoman goes in and gives him a
fake
i don't know i don't know what she gives
him but here she's saying it's antifa
again it's really [ __ ] confusing
and the reason why that works in our
favor
is because it we can actually politicize
that they don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about there's a lot
wrong there and i cannot wait for invest
real investigation is that what's going
to happen yeah we will get real but let
me say this though we will do real
investigations and she shuts up mike
glendale shut up mike
shut up
um
princess bravo points
bravado points out that um
we the people she points out that she's
an insurrectionist yeah yeah that's the
thing that's the thing um speaking of
scumbags here's another scumbag over the
weekend on face the nation
talking about both sides remember
remember i was saying that thing about
both sides earlier not both sides do not
want to take away your medicare and your
medicaid and your social security
they don't
it does not look like there is any way
to stop what is expected to be a very
big win here for for democrats and i
know you're opposed to it but i want to
press you on that because isn't
expanding medicare access good for a
state like yours which has more
residents
reliant on the affordable care act than
any other state and
does he look alive
i'm just i'm just wondering look at that
guy
look at this guy don't you yeah i
watched i watched um i think it was men
in black three
uh within the last week i know that
sounds crazy why are you watching men in
black three i don't know i don't know i
came across it the goddamn algorithm was
telling me to watch it so i watched it
but this guy looks like one of the
aliens
like you know that they dress up as a
human like he's he's a alien in a human
skin suit or some [ __ ] right rick scott
i think so let's listen to this [ __ ]
scumbag this alien scumbag republicans
like reducing the deficit the cbo says
this will reduce it for by a hundred
billion dollars over the next decade
isn't there some good stuff in here for
you too
so margaret here's the way i look at it
right now this bill actually ought to be
margaret here's the way i look at it
well what's what's
what's here the way you look at it
walking dead called the war on um
seniors act i mean
this oh man
oh man okay again with the projection
folks
again you want to know how to politicize
this [ __ ] because this guy this guy is
going to give you everything you need
right here
in this interview with face the nation
he's going to give everything you need
a why both sides are not the same
and shut up this bulls side [ __ ]
he is telling you that they want to have
a war
on old people that's what he's saying
when he says democrats this bill should
be called a war on seniors
he's saying he wants to have a war on
seniors
it's projection
folks
because i'm going to show you another
clip but just watch this is a war on
medicare you look at this this is a 280
billion dollar cut in medicare
that's it's all [ __ ] and she's gonna
uh brennan shuts it down here that's all
complete [ __ ] nonsense
but here's the thing
is that they want the war on medicare
when they're saying something it's
always projection
because this is the [ __ ] that wants to
vote on medicare and social security
every five years
so what's gonna happen is
medicare's gonna get cut and there's
gonna be seniors that don't get
life-saving drugs because reducing
medicare costs
you know that
no no he well i mean he does but he's
not going to admit it
so here's here's what is happening
is with this bill the cost of drugs is
going to go down because there's a cap
right that was the intention was to have
caps on certain drugs which is going to
reduce the cost that the government us
we the people the government which is us
have to pay for those drugs okay
which means that we get to i don't know
save the money it's not money we're just
we're saving money we're not
we're not spending extra money we're not
cutting benefits we're saving money
because we're not going to give them
those greedy bastards all of our money
let's listen
margaret it's 280 billion dollars that
would have been spent it was anticipated
to be spent it's not gonna yes he's
really upset here see the reason why
right rick scott's really [ __ ] upset
is because this guy is king medicare
medicaid fraudster okay
and when you have a medicaid medicaid
fraudster who is not going to get paid
as much
because democrats are reducing cost of
the payments that are made
to the fraudsters and that really
[ __ ] gets under his his alien skin
here
it really does it'll be spent now and
the drug companies that would be doing
more research are not going to be able
to spend the money on research there
will be life-saving drugs that seniors
will not get on top of that i mean
they're going to raise taxes by over 700
billion dollars and let's remember and
that's [ __ ] wrong
that's [ __ ] wrong no they're not
no they're not companies don't end up
paying the taxes shareholders paying the
taxes lower income for the employees pay
the taxes less investment pays the taxes
so this 700 billion dollars is actually
going to hurt the economy and then while
gas prices are two dollars
okay so here's what he's saying follow
follow the leader here oh my god this
[ __ ] bonehead what he's saying is
because people don't have to spend as
much money on their drugs and they'll
have this much money on i don't know
you know other things
he's saying he's literally saying here
that that will be bad for the economy
give me a [ __ ] break
these [ __ ] boneheads more than they
were when joe biden took office there's
an excise tax on gas so why would you
you know we're in a recession why would
you be
wrong answer we're not in a recession
we're tr they're trying to draw us into
a recession
by making money more expensive for the
middle class and the working people
they're trying to make money more
expensive and that will cause them not
to spend as much
so what the what the democrats and we
the people are trying to do rick scott
with the inflation reduction act is put
more money in the boxes pockets of
people who will spend it and when they
spend it that causes more demand and
when there's more demand there's a
better economy that's how it works these
people really
[ __ ] bone-headed to believe this
walking skeleton
increasing the cost of government
increasing taxes
so
the committee for a responsible federal
budget called your claim there that you
just reiterated um [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what they should have called it
they should have just said [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and i probably had some long [ __ ]
memo right like this is what this
is what happens see this is the reason
why we never catch up to the news cycle
that's why i tried to do it here on the
show where we just hammer these
[ __ ]
because they should have called it
[ __ ] [ __ ] and just move on it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] everything this
[ __ ] just said lies and
projection uh in terms of medicare
spending completely misleading
no no [ __ ] [ __ ]
change
we need to get a white out pin or
something up there in the studio
tell them
[ __ ] [ __ ] uh the congressional
budget office estimates that just about
one percent of new drugs would be
affected by uh the changes there on drug
development
one percent
listen to what he says
listen to how concerned he is about one
percent
now
listen
so how do you respond
wait a minute wait what if your
grandmother is not one percent important
this is the party this is the party that
was gonna leave grandma as he says
out in the cold during covert they're
like [ __ ] grandma [ __ ] her yeah [ __ ]
grandma grandpa [ __ ] old people we don't
give a [ __ ]
don't wear your mask cough on people
just have super spreader events it's no
big deal who cares if it's killing old
people don't care
if there's if if it impacts if it
impacts a life-saving drug that we could
do now
we shouldn't be we shouldn't be cutting
medicare like here you go here's the
here's the nazis head messenger
rick scott what a bonehead i can't you
know what's even more boneheaded than
rick scott saying this [ __ ] is that they
think that rick scott saying this [ __ ]
is a good idea and for him to be head of
messaging and i have another clip of
rick's got here somewhere in the
timeline i haven't even got to the
tweeted tweets and the trendy trends yet
that's how much video i got to get to
here holy [ __ ]
okay let's see
i know i got another rick scott video
here i know there's one somewhere
somewhere in this pile of videos
[Music]
where he's saying he wants to he wants
to make sure to cut yeah here it is
here's cnn uh here's rick scott talking
about how he wants to abolish medicare
and medicaid and social security after
five years listen
well let me read uh from uh some from
what you and your own plan what you say
about medicare and social security sun
setting in five years meaning it has to
be renewed every five years i assume
that includes when you say all federal
legislation must sunset in five years
does that include social security and
medicare two programs that are so
critical to seniors and you've got a lot
of seniors in your state of florida
well medicare is clearly very important
we've got to make sure we get those
benefits social security we also that's
how we do our defense budget we look at
it every year we don't say oh we're
going to have the exact same program the
exact same way uh but we know we won't
have a lethal military that could defend
the freedom of this country
well let me read oh rick scott thanks to
department of defense
is is health care for our seniors like
he believes it's the same thing so what
he wants to do now listen this is what
the [ __ ] they want to do
they want to make sure every five years
they can use
their vote for social security medicare
and medicaid against you
that's what they want they want to make
sure every five years they get to use it
against you
and eventually take it away from you
that's what they want to do they want to
take away your benefits now you're the
government right we the people are the
government we have the power of the
ballot so we can get rid of these son of
a [ __ ]
and this son of a [ __ ] is from the
great state of florida where ron
desantis marco rubio rick scott himself
and others want to make it a fascist
state down there that's their blueprint
as we've been calling here on the tony
michaels podcast
but rick scott wants and he's the head
messenger this is the guy who's setting
forth the plans for the republican party
their plan is the republican plan is to
get rid
of your health care
that is their plan
for you not to have
health care that's the plan
um also the plan
is
really weird here because
um later on in the cpac in the nazi
rally
and this is not edited as minus dutch
points out let's see if we can find it
here i got so many videos speaking of
marco rubio here's a marco rubio video
jesus christ it just doesn't end it just
doesn't stop
now i'm here's another that's now that's
the same one there's another marco rubio
rubo rubio video where he tweets out
about jewish prosecutors
and he's he's calling uh this is the
same thing they do at nazi rallies trust
me there's the alex stein video there is
a uh
a new what was that that i'm gonna play
here
uh
about matt gatz here's another donald
trump video i just have so many videos
to play
i just don't have enough time we're
gonna have to go to three hours what do
you guys think
what do you guys think should we go to
three hours
what says you in the comments now i'm
the only one here today so i haven't
been watching the comments i apologize
i've been trying to
let's see what are we adding anybody any
questions anything going on you guys get
you guys are really active i enjoy
having all you folks here every single
weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific i
love having you there for two hours
every single weekday on youtube twitter
and twitch and simulcasting from the
midas touch facebook page it is so great
to have the audience here and all the
new people coming every single day
commenting sharing liking uh building a
community of pro-democracy people
i think that's how we're going to defeat
the i think that's how
the kansas amendment got defeated in
kansas they said no [ __ ] you don't get
to have um the rights over our bodily
autonomy we get the right to have it we
are the people
everyone's saying they want us to go to
three hours oh [ __ ]
maybe i shouldn't have
gabe sanchez is gonna kick my ass
well let's do this let's watch this
short little clip
let's watch this short little clip
from the nuremburg nazi rally
and then we'll go to break but let's
watch this this is not edited
as minus touch points out this is real
we're gonna watch it a few times
soak it in
i'm telling you
we can politicize the [ __ ] out of this
watch
ladies and gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists
what
eskeep sanchez says what what was that
let's watch again
let's watch again ladies and gentlemen
we are all domestic terrorists
whoo
they literally said this [ __ ]
on stage down in cpac
and they said and they printed it up on
the big screen look at that they thought
it was so important they would announce
it and print it out
they are now self-describing themselves
as domestic terrorist
not surprising since they are that's
what the [ __ ] they are
is domestic terrorists stick around
we'll be right back right after these
messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live on your communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump it's only fifty
dollars a day i'm recurring and it means
you'll get these trump supporters the
critical help they so desperately need
to survive under this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
don't forget to contribute to the trump
fund to all the domestic terrorists out
there woohoo
oh [ __ ] you know all these videos from
gabe sanchez
they always they always come true like
they always come true it's always a
thing that happens like he does them
like two years ago and bam here they are
they're saying we're all domestic
terrorists
well we kind of knew what was that it's
over on the midas touch uh youtube
channel so go check it out but we're
gonna play it here right now
now here is gabe sanchez new new
what was that about matt gatz
and olivia bearing him and two billion
dollars worth of fundraising for
pro women causes let's listen 40
forty-year-old alleged sex trafficker
matt gates was in the news again
involving a teenager but this time it
was because gates got owned over two
million times by a 19 year old activist
[Music]
sure by now you've seen this video of
matt gates given a misogynistic and fat
phobic speech at the turning point usa
student action summit have you watched
these pro-abortion pro-murder rallies
the people
are just disgusting
like why is it
that
the women with the least likelihood of
getting pregnant are the ones most
worried about having abortions
nobody wants to impregnate you if you
look like a thumb this is actually
george carlin's joke about
anti-abortionists like mad gates but
gates tried to reverse it so he could
attack women and leave it to a
republican to steal someone else's joke
have it written on paper in front of
them and still butcher the punch
punchline also considering gates history
is anyone else concerned that he was
allowed to say this stuff let alone
being a roomful of teenagers now if you
don't know the history of butthead
looking matt gates here's some
background it should come as no surprise
that gates's former high school
classmates described him as an [ __ ]
some even said they could have predicted
his sex scandals and others they called
gates an emotional vampire in 2008 gates
was arrested for a dui after driving
back from a nightclub called the swamp
also this thing known as matt gates
coming out of the swamp seems very
fitting early on in matt gates's career
as a politician he invented a sex game
where he and his fellow male colleagues
got points for sleeping with aids
interns lobbyists and married
legislators gates also has a habit of
sharing nude photos on the house floor
of women that he has slept with you know
typical behavior for a hypocritical
god-loving christian in 2017 gates voted
against the combating human trafficking
in commercial vehicle act
surprise surprise the guy who is
currently being investigated for sex
trafficking and having sex with a minor
voted against the anti-human trafficking
bill owen in 2018 gates invited white
nationalist chuck johnson to trump's
state of the union and when gates was
asked about it he pulled a trump and
said you know the guy in 2019 gates
tweeted that florida's welcome sign
should be changed to there is no wage
that you can't be sexy something a
sexual predator would absolutely say
even matt gates's sister-in-law finds
him weird and creepy and when she was 19
gates tried to set her up with an older
man who was divorced and had a child so
then in 2021 a federal investigation was
opened up into matt gates and his friend
slash disgraced former seminole county
tax collector joel greenberg greenberg
originally faced 33 federal charges but
cut a deal with prosecutors and pleaded
guilty to six charges including sex
trafficking a minor in a confession
letter written by greenberg he says that
he and gates both paid for sex with
multiple women as well as a girl who was
17 at the time they provided cash gas
money gifts rent or partial tuition
payments via venmo also no one should be
surprised that this creep had to
literally pay girls to have sex with him
and in that very same confession letter
greenberg discusses asking roger stone
to help him secure a pardon from former
president donald trump for the price of
250 000
speaking of pardons we found out during
the january 6 hearings that matt gates
asked for a pardon for everything from
the beginning of time till now so
what is matt gates trying to hide and
how many crimes has matt gates committed
since birth and the pardons don't stop
there matt gates was also working on
getting roger stone apart him back in
2019 here's a clip that was recorded by
documentary filmmakers following roger
stone for their film a storm foretold
i'm gonna go i'll go down hard though
i'll fight it right to the bitter end
but i don't think they're gonna go down
at all at the end of the day well we'll
see
we're three weeks from trial
yeah
[Applause]
i mean
i may have to appeal to the big man
because i got it's a district columbia
we surveyed 120 jurors 90 of them know
who i am and they hate my guts
voluntarily
and then there's this audio clip of matt
gates attempting to sound like a mobster
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so jumping to this year 2022 matt gates
voted against another anti-human
trafficking bill the creep is literally
telling everyone who he is again and
what's even worse is that 19 other
republicans voted against this bill as
well it turns out that fellow
insurrectionists such as biggs bobert
brooks gomer gosar green and perry
are pro-human trafficking in the span of
five years the republican party has gone
from one person being publicly pro-human
trafficking to 20. republicans creepily
project their own sick obsession with
pedophiles people's genders and the
lgbtq community this is the same party
that forces a pregnant 10 year old rape
victim to have a child but then accuses
others of being groomers it's almost
like they're not so subtly telling us
who they really are and now that brings
us to matt gates body shaming 19 year
old activist olivia juliana quick side
note i've noticed there's a trend with
republican men getting off on harassing
women alex stein eric grains donald
trump donald trump jr i mean the list
goes on anyway back to gates he sent
this tweet with olivia's photo and this
my friends is the moment that matt gates
stepped in a huge pile of [ __ ] olivia is
one of the toughest and hardest working
activists that i know and she's not even
20 years old yet gates tried to own the
libs and what followed was a master
class in activism here's olivia on katie
fang's show so you've called gates's
comments outright misogyny and fat
phobia we reached out to the
congressman's team about those body
shaming claims this is what we got back
from gates's spokesperson quote
congressman gates never mentioned the
adult's weight leftist media did what do
you think about that official response
from matt gates's office
i think it's quite telling that gates
office would try to keep the word
teenager out of the headline
time matt gates and teenager trended
together it didn't end so well for him
wait what was that time matt gates and
teenager trended together it didn't end
so well for him olivia was able to spin
gates disgusting and hateful comments
into something positive and meaningful i
mean it wasn't even a fair fight she had
him in a chokehold within the first 24
hours and within 72 hours of his attack
olivia had raised over 1 million dollars
for abortion funds and then just 48
hours later she raised over 2 million
dollars olivia raised over 2 million off
of matt gates's forehead and at the end
of the day sex trafficker matt gates is
nothing more than a loudmouth privileged
below average white guy who got into
office due to nepotism gates has
accomplished nothing during his time as
a lawmaker other than a very long list
of scandals you know people say don't
mess with texas but i feel like the real
lesson here is don't [ __ ] with texas
women way to go olivia well i'm gabe
sanchez and this has been what was that
[Music]
there you have it what was that a brand
new version from gabe sanchez
over on the midas touch youtube channel
go check out gabe sanchez new new
edition what was that about matt gatz
over on the midas touch network uh you
go over there it should be on the
facebook page i'm sure it'll be on the
twitter page as well we'll spread that
thing around the interwebs like herpes
as we normally do you know that's what
we like to do we like to spread the good
stuff around
okay let's go back to the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends and i don't want
to leave out some topics today i still
have a ton of video i want to get to um
but i definitely wanted to play gabe's
new version of what was that so go over
and give him some love on the tubes of
you if you would for us please now let's
see here
uh millie was uh trending
and the reason why millie mark millie
general mark milley was trending is
because
of the resignation letter that he was
about to write um one of the
quotes from it and let me see if i can
find it real quick a tweet that's got it
and i quote i i tweeted it here and see
if we can find it nip
i don't know now let's see let's go to
the top see this is what happens when
you're by yourself this is what happens
oh here page has it paige williams says
it is my belief you are doing great and
irreparable harm to our country she
quotes general mark milley from his
resignation text
a resignation letter as it were to
donald trump that he never delivered now
again this is a letter a resignation
letter that was never delivered to
donald trump
from general mark milley
but let's face it folks if we would have
known this back in 2020 from mark milley
that this is the way he felt that he was
going to deliver a resignation letter
that would that
included the words it is my belief that
you're doing a great in rampable harm to
my
country
i think it may have turned some heads
back then what do you think now paige
points it out here in this new york
article by peter baker i believe that's
who wrote it yes peter baker um so check
out the mark milly story let's go back
to the tweety tweets here let's see what
else is trending kanye's trending
apparently he's uh trolling
uh pete davidson pete davidson and kim
kardashian broke up
who gives a [ __ ] who gives a ratchet
listen we got a lot
we got a lot more [ __ ] to [ __ ] talk
about and to be concerned about than
kanye west trolling pete davison for
break for kim kardashian breaking up
with him the [ __ ] out of here that
nonsense more that
we can stick that on the both sides side
of the fence of who gives a [ __ ] um here
is a breaking story breaking travis
mcmichael who fatally shot ahmad aubry
is receiving a second life sentence for
his federal hate crimes now it looks
like he's going to get a federal charge
of light or excuse me sentence of life
for the charge of hate crimes um cbs
news is reporting
uh so there is justice being served in
the amman aubry a case for his family
and for ahmad aubry himself
where the father and the son team
decided it would be okay if they just
cold-blooded murdered a black man
because he was running while black
um in that case of
of ahmad aubry travis mcmichael will
serve
a second life sentence in federal prison
uh let's see here here's some
interesting news that may come to the
forefront tornado cash which is a
cryptocurrency
um has been helping hackers launder
money yeah no [ __ ] sherlock why do you
think so many people are [ __ ] scared
of crypto
like crypto bros are like no man it's
the future it's the future man it's the
future yeah right it may be the future
but right now it's horrible it sucks
it's horrible they're using it for
horrible things yeah
let's see what else do we have here um
seoul is on the list the parts kind of
occurring um torrential downpours looks
like there's more climate change weather
across the world in seoul south korea
which is not surprising that it's
affecting
other parts of the world than just here
because that's how climate change works
the planet is trying to get rid of us we
are a parasite
we are doing bad things to the planet
mother nature is trying to get rid of us
okay west point
let's see what do we have on our west
point what what's what's the um what the
hell is the deal here
what's going on here
oh jesus christ did this guy [ __ ]
post something about west point
oh my god
okay here's the
uh cheeto dust monster mango mussolini
jesus
apparently posting something about west
point um
a man i know just informed me that his
son a very good student at west point
is leaving because the school has gone
radical left and woke
he has already picked a very good
university trump university i'm sure
ah what the [ __ ] is going on here
um
ron tweets west point well-known bastion
of marxism yeah no [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
are you talking about this is this is
this is just bonkers ass [ __ ]
bonkers as [ __ ] look
empathy and decency is not wokism okay
and even if empathy and decency is
wokism i'm all for wokism
if it's just like simple decency and
empathy this is really [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ]
this is really stupid [ __ ]
oh my god west point good good riddance
that's what west point should feel
that's how they should feel about this
story good
riddance um the irs is going to approve
funding 80 million dollars
um for over 10 years
which apparently includes 87 000 irs
agents finally our irs will actually
work for us did you know
i don't know if you guys know this
accounting firms they have like rooms
with telephones
or they'll just use their telephones and
they'll be like four phones
that ring into the irs waiting for an
irs agent to pick up
and as soon as they have an irs agent
pick up they have like i don't know 20
30 questions that they have to ask for
their clientele
to the irs because the irs is
the government it's us it's our tax
agency
it's our agency that we have to make
sure that we
control all the taxes that revenue in
revenue all that kind of stuff right
hold people accountable who are tax
cheats donald trump um
but here's the thing
is when they say hiring 87 000 irs
agents they don't mean like people with
badges and guns that go out and arrest
you and audit you that's not what
they're talking about they're talking
about simple irs agents that answer the
phone to answer your question
about your taxes that you are required
to pay it's really [ __ ] stupid this
is nonsense this is absolute nonsense
that people in this country don't want
irs agents
to make sure that the irs operates
efficiently so that we can get a hold of
them when they're trying to seize our
bank accounts
sometimes there's like clerical errors
right and the irs will write you a
letter
and then you can't get a hold of them
you can't get ahold of them you can't
get a hold of them
because there's not enough of them
because they're not an efficient enough
agency to run
the the tax portion of our government
the revenue department of our government
and we need them
there running that revenue department
efficiently efficiently and effectively
for us jesus christ this is really
bone-headed [ __ ] um and another headline
axios
axios sells to cox enterprises for
525 million dollars holy [ __ ]
that's a lot of money axios is not is
not an old company actually this is a
brand new company
i don't know if you know this but
they're kind of like a
axios does these little like bullet
style type articles
um it's actually a really unique way to
deliver news um but 525 million dollars
to cox enterprises you know that um
uh axios lost their their well they just
didn't renew their contract for like
their documentaries on hbo we saw a lot
of really great interviews from axios on
hbo but they didn't renew that contract
hbo didn't um because of you know hbo
plus and some other things that cnn did
it's just a whole thing
but axios sells to cox enterprises which
is a cable broadcast um they're a cable
company so that should be interesting
maybe maybe maybe maybe
we're we're going to have some changes
in the media because that's what we
really need folks because there's a lot
of this bull sizing [ __ ] that i was
talking about earlier in the [ __ ]
media a lot of it and we need to get
them to stop that [ __ ] that is nonsense
we do not have to put up with the bull
sizing from
the the uh
from the media uh maggie haberman
uh
actually
wrote a story i guess or posted pictures
i don't know mike uh sington has the
pictures here
trump dumps
new york times maggie haberman obtains
photos from white house source of
documents with trump's handwriting on
them in two different toilets
oh on the left is a toilet in the wine
house on the right uh is from overseas
trip trump took
at trump dump overseas i guess uh trump
reportedly flushed documents repeatedly
okay so here's the thing
here's the pictures right and you see on
this one
uh down in the bottom of this one it
says rogers apparently
or roger s maybe i don't know for
stodger roan i don't know maybe i don't
i don't know
but it says stefanik you can see the
name stephonic which is a very unique
name
in elise stefanik
he flushed notes about elise stefani now
these are trump's handwriting so this
isn't like someone else wrote notes he
took them from them
tore them up and threw them down the
toilet he was taking notes
himself
and then he decided that they were
evidence maybe and he would tear them up
and throw them and flush them because he
wrote them he didn't want anything in
his or handwriting i guess here's the
thing
these notes that he's flushing are our
notes
he did them while he was in our office
it's
our government we
are
the government
it's us
it's the people
it's the citizens it's our [ __ ]
government and the office of the
presidency is held by the person that we
the government decide to hold that
[ __ ] office
and they are required whoever the
president is i don't give a [ __ ] who it
is they're required
to actually catalog and archive all the
records that take place while they hold
that office our office
our office
it's our presidential office in our
government
we need to stop
not thinking about this as a democracy
and really lean in to democracy because
it's working folks it is working
and i knew it would the reason why it's
working is because democracy is
fascism's enemy it always has been
always will be that's why they hate it
but here you have
pictures
of trump notes being flushed down to it
now my question is with these with these
pictures
someone someone took these pictures
someone took these pictures
did they have a habit of going in after
trump and taking pictures of the toilet
i'm just saying
wow where where did these pictures come
from who is this person who is walking
in after trump
and taking pictures
of the commode
after he's been in there think about it
how many big old trump dump pictures do
you think there are
like pictures of his actual [ __ ] not not
of his him committing treason
and breaking his oath here not that
but actually taking a dump i mean really
they had a habit of going in after him
and taking a picture apparently holy
actual [ __ ]
kind of ridiculous but you know that
that's how it goes
now let's see what hal has to say here
here's how oh how how post a picture uh
meanwhile trump's putin's bodyguards
collect his poop on trips abroad
what what what oh hell
hell sparks
pointing out that putin's bodyguards
collect his poop
whoa oh hell
how how hell okay let's go back to the
tweety tweets and training trends let's
see what else we have and the shitless
roundup um the democrats is trending of
course the democrats are trending
because the democrats are actually
working for the american people they are
the party
of democracy here rachel bittikoffer
even though she couldn't join us
she joins us
from the tweets
she says joe biden and the democrats
deliver pass it on
thank you rachel bittikoffer
dr rachel bittikoffer we missed her
today i was so i was maybe maybe i'll
try to get her on
um tomorrow or wednesday what do you
guys think mayo here one of our
favorites says today the democrats
kicked the republicans right in the nuts
goddamn right they did
kicking names and taking ass okay let's
see
what else
what else do we have here under the
democrats is there any video uh here's a
recount oh here's fox and friends
they must be freaking out over
this bill passing to reduce inflation
let's listen
how the dingleberries are spinning it so
jackie is there a money-back guarantee
from the democrats that it definitely
will reduce inflation because oh my god
oh my god what in the [ __ ] is this guy
talking about
what the [ __ ] listen listen
when you reduce the cost of things
because you put a cap on them you're
reducing the cost of them that's what
you [ __ ] have been complaining
about
for months they've been complaining oh
gas prices things are so high what are
we gonna do what's joe biden and the
democrats doing they're not holding
hearings on inflation they're not
they're not lowering gas prices
well here the president united states
and his administration worked very hard
to make sure to fix the supply chain
problem with crude oil as russia invades
a sovereign nation and is murdering
women and children in war crimes and the
world says no we are not going to
support you in that effort we are
cutting off
your supply of crude to the world we're
not going to buy
blood-stained crude oil
and the administration and the world
frankly all the world leaders including
our president president joe biden work
hard to fix
that supply chain they fix it and it
brings it down
brings crude oil down to below 90
dollars a barrel
the first time since vladimir putin
decided to invade ukraine and start
murdering women and children
and war crimes in his effort to take a
sovereign nation
now
you've been complaining about that that
problem seems to be going in the
opposite direction you've been
complaining about the cost of goods oh
it's killing americans and here is a
bill who that literally caps the price
of one of the main things that strains
americans budgets
really
without cause is prescription drugs well
just one of the things just one of them
in the bill you can just get that one
out and the reason why you want to get
that one out of the bill is because
republicans voted against capping
insulin at 35
so they wanted higher prices and you
want lower prices that they've been
bitching about
the [ __ ] out of here this is nonsense
let's
let's listen to what other kind of [ __ ]
they puke up here it's called the
inflation reduction act you would think
that it's a reduced inflation
uh one would hope maybe
we hope it doesn't
we hope it doesn't reduce inflation
because if it actually reduces inflation
that kills our message oh that really
kills our message that democrats aren't
doing anything to reduce inflation and
they are
the democrats are the only [ __ ]
that are interested
in even discussing reducing inflation
republicans are voting against it
they're voting against it
they voted against [ __ ] making sure
corporations were held in account the
oil companies for not gouging people
they voted against getting baby
to babies
they voted against the inflation
reduction act they don't give a [ __ ]
about you
so go out there and do what you do best
pro democracy people do democracy engage
in the ballot
make sure you're armed with these things
that's why i try to give you these these
little video clips and proof and little
bits of evidence of why
fascists are fascist
and why people who have a little bit of
empathy a sense of decency
and but really don't understand that
there is a huge difference
a huge difference between between
someone who is pro-democracy who
believes in democracy who believes in
our former government and who is an
american and a patriot and someone who
is
um
fascist who believes in american fascism
i don't know
um
trumpism there you go there's a good
word for it
white christian nationalism there's the
one that they like to use american nazis
just show them this stuff i'm telling
you you start to show this stuff to
people and i'm not just talking about
send it to their inbox i mean stand
there physically stand there and show
this to them now let's see if we can get
them some warm footage oh
oh this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] so i tweeted about
this too
um this is uh another
vile
vampire looking [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
this guy this nazi here stephen miller
listen to what he has to say john
stephen first the border which you have
been raising the alarms on now for years
you have studied this for decades then
why didn't you [ __ ] fix it
you were gonna fix it remember that's
what the [ __ ] that's the whole [ __ ]
point that's the whole point
is that they were gonna fix it remember
only i can fix it remember
build the wall remember that was gonna
fix everything i was gonna make it great
it was gonna make america great again
remember all that nonsense all that
drivel all that vile [ __ ]
why didn't you people do that when you
were in why why didn't you do anything
about it if it's so [ __ ] bad
and then every time every time border
security
actually
seizes a bunch of fentanyl
thousands and thousands of pounds of
fentanyl a guy like this dumb [ __ ] goes
oh look joe baden is failing because
they're seizing fentanyl at the border
like isn't that what you want it's the
same thing we're like oh look at
democrats passing the in inflation
reduction act they're they're not doing
anything about inflation because we're
in a recession just just [ __ ] lies
let's listen to the lies that he pukes
up tell us how you see things today
we are in the midst of the greatest
national security crisis and greatest
humanitarian crisis that we have ever
seen okay that's enough that's enough
you know what yeah and i tweeted this
i'm so happy
i am so happy watching this clip here's
what makes me happy about this clip
that this [ __ ] piece of garbage
this piece of vile garbage is no longer
in our white house
he is he is relegated to go on fox news
and whine like a little [ __ ]
but he does not have the reins of our
government he's not inside our white
house
so there you go that's what i see about
that clip um let's go back to my
timeline because i have a few more
videos i want to show we got just about
oh we're almost to the top of the second
hour see i think we need three hours
are you folks out there all in agreement
that three hours everyone was saying yes
before you really think you can handle
three hours
you think you can do it i don't know and
we'll see uh let's go down i have some
more video that i do want to show
um
[Music]
we showed that one oh here we go this is
that uh herschel walker ad from the
republican accountability project it's
not very long real short easy to share
easy to show to all your relatives
anyone in georgia you should spread this
around georgia like it's [ __ ] herpes
let's watch
do you think you know herschel walker
[Applause]
well think again
listen to what his ex-wife had to say
about him his eyes would become very
evil the guns and knives i got into a
few choking things with him the first
time he held the gun to my head he
yelled the gun to my temple
and said
he was gonna blow my brains out
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't take it from me
take it from his ex-wife
uh
minus touch says it right every georgia
voter needs to say this see this
so spread this around the internet go
ahead spread this around the internet
here's texas paul in my timeline he he
gave a reaction um about dick cheney
over on youtube you should go check it
out um speaking of texas pearl texas
paul will be back with us tomorrow
texas paul tuesday
now he's got a few subjects in texas he
wants to talk to us tomorrow on tuesday
about so don't miss that tomorrow texas
paul will join us at the bottom of the
first hour i'm sure as long as we don't
have any technical difficulties and i'll
try to get rachel bittikoffer on
tomorrow or wednesday
um see if we can get her back on to talk
about the uh the nazi rally down in
texas which i'm sure texas paul is gonna
have a thing or thing thing or two to
say
about the nuremberg rally that was held
in his home state so stay tuned tomorrow
you're not going to want to miss a texas
ball makes his uh entry back to
back
to the tony michaels podcast for texas
paul tuesday here's michael beschloss um
he posted this youtube link here uh of a
it is
from the group
um let's see what is the group called i
forget what the group is called here
anyways here's the thing he says if you
have seven minutes available please
watch a night at the garden from 2018.
that's the name of the documentary it's
only seven minutes which is very very
key here
it would be very easy to get someone to
watch a seven minute documentary
okay it's from the academy award
nominated documentary by marshall curry
on the chilling 1939 nazi organized
rally in madison square garden where 22
000 people attended look
if there's some nazis
in an arena
and 22 000 people are there to see the
nazis you got 22 000 nazis okay
okay
this is in 1939 folks actually you know
what let's go let me go i'm gonna go to
the uh
the youtube channel here
um because i believe they have a
if i'm not mistaken they actually have a
30-second little
um
like a trailer for it right
just a short little trailer and i'll
show you the trailer so you guys can see
um what i'm talking about because we i
don't have time to play the whole the
the to do the whole seven minutes um
but maybe i'll put it on a playlist or
something but the link is there on
michael bechlash's uh
his tweet let's see if i can find it
that's the seven minute one air there
this one here that's the one we want
that's what we want okay well we'll play
this here um
we'll get this is the trailer for it
and let me bring that down so i can get
get this ready here
let's see here there we go okay so we'll
we'll uh we'll play this trailer here so
this is the trailer for
the night at the garden
it can happen here
this is the
again this is the
the trailer let's watch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so go watch
uh a night at the garden
um again it's about the 1939
nazi rally that they held america first
rally and they actually have george
washington it's kind of some really
crazy imagery that they use george
washington and they actually called him
america's first fascist
i'm not [ __ ] you the american nazis
back in 1939 used a big huge picture of
george washington
in the very front
of the arena you saw it there
and they
called him george washington america's
first
fascist
um it was an america first rally they
were super excited about it so go go
make sure
to check out that documentary again uh
let me see if i can i'll retweet this to
get it at the top of the timeline
um i think it's worthwhile watch it's
only seven minutes um i've seen it
before but i rewatched it again this
morning
before i came
on here here it is again here's
michael's uh tweet
uh give him credit and i'll also go
ahead and re undo retweet and retweet
did you know that that'll put it well
sometimes yeah damn it it's not putting
at the top of the timeline i'll get it
i'll get it it's all right come in then
we'll do this
go watch
uh
night at the
garden
so we'll tweet there go watch the night
of the garden
so go check out
a night at the garden let your families
your friends see it
especially right after this
um
cpac nuremberg rally that we had down in
texas where they were claiming that they
want to all be domestic terrorists um
before we go david again i don't know
where gabe was but he said he ran into
kimberly gilford on donald trump jr at
the grocery store what do you think
donald trump looks like [ __ ] man
guy needs to lay off the booger sugar
here
gabe sanchez never fails i missed him
today i know you guys did too i'm glad
we had that what was that so we had we
had a little bit of
gabe time in there
mayo tweets orange donald is no match
for dark brandon
orange donald
is no match for dark brandon none of
this bullside [ __ ]
listen to mayo
she's spot on folks
until tomorrow noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific right here on youtube
twitter
and twitch
and simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page don't forget to follow us
right here on youtube subscribe to our
channel don't miss a thing you can also
download every single episode on apple
spotify google your favorite directories
and do us a favor
while you're there on your favorite
directory leave us
leave us a great review five stars
whatever they do over there five stars
ten out of ten whatever the directory
does also follow us on twitter at
tonymichaelspod you can follow us over
there you can also go to
thetonymichaels.com
thetonymichaels.com
find all kinds of links and all the
links to all the social media mine games
and everyone else is over there on
thetonymichaels.com
until
tomorrow surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking